in this agent staining image we can see  the structures of  certain epithelium over here in this  epithelial tissue you will be able to  appreciate certain cells which are  flattened and they have small nucleus in  the middle now all these flattened cells  that you can appreciate over here have a  nucleus but this nucleus in this  flattened cells are dorsoventally  flattened  this type of cells are known as your  squamous cell  and they make up the squamous epithelium  now this Squamish epithelium has a  function of exchange and diffusion and  this image is an image of lung tissue  where gaseous exchange takes place